Mike my hearty thank you for joining us
thanks for having me in the lobby today
first of all we talked about far crying
a little hot second first of all I want
to talk to you about sky fortresses oh
man so just just jet humans yeah just
goes three DLCs coming ash you can turn
Rico into an f-16 or whatever yeah it
turns a wingsuit it's powered by by
bavarian that's substance that you're
trying to radioactive oh really
substance you're trying to fight over in
a in the base game and now it just
powers your wingsuit like infinite not
infinite booster you could stay in the
air for however long you want you have
like a chain gun on one shoulder missile
launcher on the other you do strafing
runs and then turn on a dime kind of
he's literate that's crazy yeah what is
it is it fun yeah it's really fun what
else you doing it look what is the DNC
Disick sky fortress up doesn't plug into
just go three proper is like a separate
mission there's a certain mission that
you go to upgrade the wingsuit and then
you can just the sky fortress is
actually floating you can get to it from
wherever you can use that you can or wow
here it is you can use this say for
instance somebody like me who has only
like played I've only unlocked half the
bases in the game I haven't touched the
big island yet if I was to get this DLC
do you think I'll be able to use that
suit to take out all those you would be
able to get it soon yeah you would
probably need a little more few more
upgrades to actually take on the sky
fortress because it was like an upper
level outpost I don't know if we'll see
gameplay of it but it so the sky
fortress is divided into two of those
outposts so there's the bow section and
the stern would you both have their own
things you need to destroy and there's
like an underbelly to it where a lot of
its power cores are that you need to
take out what and it's also the main
enemies are all drones so these drone
dispensers you can get your own one to
like kind of fly around support you and
distract enemies and shoot them and yeah
the majority of people i was there not
people the majority of enemies i was
fighting were drones from the eaton
corporation they didn't tell me too much
about the story so i don't know what's
going on with like two hours did not
seem like about the length of it no they
said it should take you it could take
you like four without if you do all the
story missions i guess i was also still
getting acclimated to it again so it's
taken me longer than it might if i had
been playing just cause 3 right before a
lot you know I played about 20 something
hours back when I was reviewing it but
since then I haven't been able to play
it too much so it's kind of
rusty cool that's out in March yatris
unspecified day in March and then two
months after that will be the land base
it's like air land and sea dlc turn into
a motorcycle my god you know it's a mac
actually it's like a giant floating mac
hover merit and then after that two
months after that will be the c1 which
is a sea heist yeah you're a surfboard
of machine-gun my back you ride around
in dolphin with chain guns perfect oh
wait I'm true no no I well I mean it's
their call now they're watching no it's
I haven't side too much about it it's
just a sea heist like on yachts and
stuff cool so like Ocean's eleven adios
no I didn't mean that I swear all right
this guy for it did it seem fun like
that yeah really fun uh especially if
you played a lot of Just Cause might be
nothing to bring you back in because I
feel like 20 hours and I haven't i've
only done half the [ __ ] game oh yeah
so this should be I mean just it makes
it even more ridiculous than it already
is so and it's they're making they have
no qualms about that they're just going
for it excellence which I appreciate you
looking forward to see more thanks so
much